we are preoccupied with ourselves in
unhelpful ways the clouds however know
nothing of us they float by utterly
unaware of our concerns these vast quiet
things are always too and there is a
constant drama of our heads collisions
fractures swirl separations human life
is no less active but it can be a moment
of relief from our particular
involvement Stu look up and be returned
to a broader perspective from where the
agitations of the here-and-now seem less
significant it will all pass even the
current nastiness and anxiety like the
clouds that seem so fixed and heavy but
now are ago and yet have now moved on
leaving behind only two or three of
their numbers
apologetic and timid before the
victorious Sun like the coward remnants
of a scattered army they are an image of
patience and resolution their gnarled
worn bark
speak of the hundreds of seasons they've
endured they've bent and lost branches
in winter winds
they've been gnawed at by worms and
beetles across the airless days of
summer they've been knocked and hacked
at by farmers and children but they
endure as we might better learn to do
through their examples all those leaves
resplendent in the summer Sun will soon
be gone
human life is as terminal but it is the
example of trees that best and most
gracefully introduce us to the
inevitable facts of the life cycle
nothing will be forever so the trees
enjoy these precious days whisper their
leaves they are always communicating
whispering exclaiming arguing with a
rock or a twig confiding in a quiet
vortex dozing in midsummer all shouting
in a rage after a heavy shower like
fires they provide an ideal object of
contemplation their constant activity in
live-ins the imagination but don't stare
blankly back at us like pieces of paper
on a desk they distract our minds just
enough that the good ideas the ones that
we hate to ask ourselves directly can
feel relieved of pressure and slip out
and we can make progress with ourselves
we need nature not just for physical
health but as importantly for sanity no
week should be count and complete if it
doesn't include one or two minutes given
over to the clouds the trees and the
streams emissaries of perspective
patience and introspection
you